міхури пишні
оболонської природи розкльошений
дошкільний навчальний заклад
номер 291 заварну на свою радість дикий
вітальні відкрив двері для всіх дітей
з 2007 року
у рамках реалізації програми
інклюзивного свято дітей із синдромом
дауна нашому садочку фон ціною інклюзів
на група група
дикий razon para буває 2 вигляді ти йди ти
із синдромом дауна
десь живуть і розум спин зростають на
буває новачки жити а в суть розум і розум
роздивлятися виставили вільховий театр
їм дістануся доля тих, що летять en scene як
ви карстовий кіра шкурі пасивний kia і
спортивне обладнання
розум знають на про гулянках tous pour ти
мені залі
інклюзивна група форми тя таким чином
рахунку не було комфортно всім дітям
здоровим і пим юки травень особливості у
розвитку важливі його ще по шаблі вас
дітей компенсувалося а позитивними
можливості ми
інших
venterra ваній групі
нормально вихідні процес йтиму за
традиційними прямо ми на приклад
пізнаємо ми не дітей і знову про зайве
свиту розвитку мови мовчання кульгати і
розвитку математично хуя волин
образотворчою реальністю
констру юван ним язичний йому зичним
вишиванням
викури 100 вийти також in і традиції не
на прямі падав особисті діяльності
наприклад гра го терапія логоритміка
психогімнастика розвиток соціального
таку нікотин на васпі у вбивство
то ваші і у вас ранка валюти а б її
називають рангову колу і годину дроту не
близько про групу
створи тобі трохи області радості
че хіба куна не я писав участь іграх
коротких та шви таких заняттях таких
груп 2 заняття проводяться за різьбленими
тематикам
душки нам у віті праведною ідеальністю
євро
процесі гри розвивається символічно
функція а я по фантазія
дитину ви курей з тави та предмети за про
і значенням сама обара і збирали
вугри де ти за свою норму вид але син
між людьми
частина я її буду вати
навчає старої вчися розум зірка
живим та дітьми
здатні води ти на чиїйсь то говорить і
дієти
вона адаптується до нормального життя
а
музика естетично діяльності дошкільному
закладі розлітається як тілесна система
садочку чудово музика залу
така досить формула з приватним і
технічним та за собою
м'язовий центр караоке
закон, чиїх музичних інструментів та
добре до
організовані muse креником світла
розвалі несу страшний естетичний дув
і не і дітям тютюнкам кори стоїте
популярністю садочку заняття злого
ритміки
за свій рідна форма активної терапії
якоб і оля гая поїдання слова музики
харухи
логопеди що ритмі коливай на заданий
тонус організму на мотори куна на нас 3d
тен і кури зовсім особливі вам аличі
майці че
інча порушення могло небо у розвитку
проводить заняття дефектолог там вдалий
педагог
добрий організовану та роботу з дітьми
що мають води блискавка з ним і пройти і
читали але у пет її робота дає horny
результати рушницю прийняти до діапазону
спилку вання та за голом розвитку дитини
групи we заняття проводяться за
кутовими
і здоровим і дітьми за різьбленими
програмам
в закладі створа наумова для забезпечення
оптимального рукава гори живу та спорт та
на зали порізана монетним кутом знанням
спортивної топи крові майданчики
фізкультурник качки по всіх хутряних
групам ще для ніг відводиться дістати
ділянці на різанини в і для рукава
активності дітей я коронкову на стику
фізкультурні заняття та скільки волинки
артерій гри
на високому рівні організована спочатку
вихідні процес
мій or нам це тисяч на базу ви
хрестової оновити не дасть вона не
побутової йти реально закривати джо йти
у світ не процес з учасником наукова
методичні підходи особливі з місця
хлопець-то ванною і я лісові
integra ванний психологи зайти
останнього процесу
використання з максимальною
продуктивністю та акт перевірених
останніх технологій так і вкриватиме дружина
практику і на водяних організаціях під
процесу проходьте до віч та інші форми
яке будинок особливо stay
психофізичного розвитку дужки ники
основні форми роботи колективно
хрупова індивідуально
друк колективних форм роботи з дітьми
іншу в 1 годину та 3 педагоги
бихова ти психолог колективний подарунок
колективна стеля індивідуальна
роботу організовані на основі
індивідуального початкового плану
та їм результаті та correctod поставлених
роби учасникам та вихідного процесу
для досягнення результатів
нам
шкоду організовану початкову
діяльністю балика у баха
визначається через стіну митця
ідеальності
струмує я розбивку творчо
потенціалу
розвитку стародавні моторики рук промивання
асоціативного мислення
про в'язницю ви хапай просто приділяю хвилю
лише листи поділи ми на праховий черговий і
подовгу nasty bits
всім а люки майка чогось себе
повноцінними людьми нашої істоти
яких розуміють і пряма такими і
акімова ни е
головне ще грим пивних рівного світу
сидить і маюги ремені та права ось і
щасливими